hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith and today we've got a
seat for you at the ultimate Hollywood
power lunch table let's take a look at
what happens when you bring the year's
most successful filmmakers together in
one room inside the nominees lunch the
nominee luncheon is basically your first
stop to our season 4 nominee it's an
opportunity for nominees to get together
and celebrate the fact that they are
part of history it is somewhat private
and that the nominees can really applaud
one another and for some of them it's
the highlight of the whole awards season
it's such a small guest count and
there's a huge percentage of nominees
it's a roomful of the top filmmakers and
artists in our industry and it's an
opportunity for them to gather together
for the big show we hold the lunch every
year at the Beverly Hilton we set up a
red carpet and so the press is there
taking photographs of the nominees we
then have the nominees go and be
interviewed by the press we've got
entertainment reporters bloggers so it's
a brief opportunity for them to further
get to know the nominees we then sit
down for delicious lunch
it isn't just tables of same nominees
it's all broken up so a Best Actor
nominee could be with the best
cinematographer nominee with the best
costume designer nominees so it's all
kind of a very communal celebration of
their honor being nominated for the year
and it's one of the best and warmest of
the events they're everything it's not
about the decor it's not about the music
it's not about that nothing about the
food is about them during of that
luncheon our president has a welcome
Craig and I get up on stage and we make
some opening remarks about celebrating
the great during the filming president
Academy will call them one by one and
honor them with a certificate of
nomination so as each of their names are
read there's a real sense of goodwill
amongst them so you hear a lot of
cheering you hear a lot of support for
each nominee from other nominees
one of the most exciting moments of the
nominee luncheon is really the photo it
really does take you back to when you're
in junior high or high school and you
all come up on these bleachers and take
this photo and to watch essentially
you're the greatest filmmakers of the
year and climb on these bleachers I'll
gather together in no particular order
and stand there for a photo it's pretty
amazing and there's such great goodwill
support friendship and sense of
community between all of them it's just
you know really fun to see that kind of
spirit amongst them last year they were
busting at the seams almost at the edge
of the riser doesn't look that way in
the photo they actually get to stand
there as a class representing the Oscars
it's just really iconic and traditional
and a great moment in history you see
major celebrities being completely
starstruck when they meet other
celebrities it adds a level of humanity
almost that's what I need to see that
this year it's been a great year in film
and and there will be a lot of deserving
nominees it's gonna be our biggest year
yet everyone is essentially a winner at
that that afternoon so that's what makes
it so special
four more nominees lunch highlights
check out our gallery of past nominee
class photos only on Oscar com